This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey there, this is Chris
Abraham.
This is the Chris Abraham show.
My name is Chris Abraham
formerly known as Chris cast.
This is season 5 episode 2.
The last episode was in January
and I'm starting again because
one person on Mastodon said that
they won their wondering if I'm
still podcasting and see.
Honestly, it's not like I need a
thousand people to keep me
going.
I just need to know.
Oh that I'm not yelling into
space like a madman.
So as long as I'm heard by one
person, it is worth it.
To me.
I will come back and tell you
about why I've returned to
podcasting today is a special
day, in many ways talk to you
soon.
Hey, today is March 8th.
Today is my birthday.
Today is international women's
day.
Women's day today, I'm 53 years
old and yesterday, I jumped on
the scale, my Withings smart
scale and it told me that I was
298 point five pounds.
Now, I make a lot of promises of
the old and I sort of challenge
myself for a lot of things.
And I often times come short,
come up short, but I promised
myself that I would be under 300
pounds by my birthday.
So 200 98.5 is cutting it close.
Not a lot of buffer but I did
it.
So I'm very happy about that.
So I took today off and really
just completely farted around
and now I'm doing this and it's
Wednesday.
I didn't plan anything for
today.
In fact, I believe I kept my
head down, so as not to be
responsible to or for anything.
Today, I can start again in the,
the Sisyphus Ian task of my
life, but for Today, it was just
chillax.
I didn't even Do anything.
I cooked a very large hamburger
patty and spoiled myself,
because I know I know that my
cardiologist is going to at the
end of three months on the 13th
or 14th 14th is going to allow
me to have guacamole and yellow
squash and zucchini and olives
and And so, I took the liberty
yesterday of buying some olives
and buying some guacamole, and
even though guacamole is in
strict carnivore, nor is it just
strictly avocado.
I wanted to have some.
So yesterday I Glutton and I
know I just got the 298 measure
on the scale, but I went and
yesterday afternoon, I first of
all, I made a beef burger
breakfast and then had a an
omelet, a tidy toes and then
couldn't help myself.
I bought a bunch of Olives.
I bought a grocery store,
chicken, and I bought some
guacamole and I made a feast of
it last night.
And this morning I guacamole
over left over.
So I cooked up another giant
beef burger patty and I
smothered it in guacamole.
So that's pretty much all I ate
today.
I had a couple other things but
hopefully that did derail my
diet I want to lose Another 80
pounds, so wish me luck on that.
But everybody wants to hear how
it happened and all the stories
about it.
So, right after this brief
break, I will try to just sort
of soliloquy about the process
and what worked, and what didn't
work and all those other things.
Alright, coming back, oh, very
flawed, at the tldr, or no?
You know, I will give you a
brief peak in terms of the next
segment and there's a lot of up
and ups and downs.
Not, everything's perfect.
There were a lot of plateaus, a
lot of lost ground and it wasn't
easy, but it's not hard either.
Be right back. alright, so six
months ago, I was 350 pounds and
high A1C.
Hey, Google, what is a high A1C
mean On the website.
Cdc.gov.
They say your A1C result.
The normally one sea level is
below 5.7%.
A level of 5.7% to 6.4%
indicates pre-diabetes.
And a level of 6.5% are more
indicates.
Diabetes within the five point
seven percent to six point four
percent pre-diabetes range, the
higher your A1C.
The greater your risk is for
developing type 2 diabetes.
So, six months ago, I visited my
cardiologist and he did Labs on
me and the A1C and the indicated
diabetes, he called me, and he
called me, like, after I left,
he called me, when I was at
Giant Food, he called me on my
cell phone and said, Chris
eccentric, maybe you should get
this.
This, we need to make you lose
weight, this eccentric thing is
for diabetes, you need to give
yourself a shot once a week in
the belly fat and that kind of
stuff and So, but on that day,
when we were at the appointment,
he said to me, listen, wink,
wink.
I can't prescribe this to you,
wink, wink.
But I feel like it's time to be
extreme.
So he unofficially.
Prescribed me with a carnivore
diet.
And hey, Google.
Tell me about a restrictive
carnivore diet.
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
Hey Google.
What is the carnivore diet?
According to Wikipedia, the
carnivore diet is a
low-carbohydrate fad diet in
which only animal products such
as meat eggs, and dairy are
consumed.
The carnivore diet is not
supported by evidence based
medicine, and it has attracted
criticism from dietitians and
Physicians who have stated the
diet could lead to vitamin
deficiencies and increased risk
of chronic disease.
Hey, Google.
What is a restrictive diet.
On the website.
Rachel a.com they say
restrictive diets or any type of
diet that cutout major food
groups are calories for the sake
of losing weight or reducing fat
people.
Also, sometimes ask me what is
considered a restricted diet?
Do you want to hear the answer?
Yes.
On the website, need a DOT
nih.gov, they say calorie.
Restriction means reducing
average, daily caloric intake
below.
What is typical or habitual
without malnutrition or
deprivation of essential
nutrients.
In a fasting diet, a person does
not eat at all or severely
limits intake During certain
times of the day, week or month.
I don't think I mean that
though, I think hey, Google,
what is it called?
When you limit your diet based
on maybe being allergic to
things?
I don't know, but I found these
results on search.
I think, restricted know there's
a term for when you stop eating
things to check out whether or
not you're allergic or have
inflammation.
And I don't remember what the
word is, but it is that, right?
So the biggest thing that dr.
Lux my cardiologist thinks I'm
suffering from is a big problem
with inflammation.
That's To be the gut of all the
problems that I'm having.
So by reducing the number of
types of foods that I can eat
for, it's been six months now
because he was so amazed at the
at the appointment after 3
months that my diabetes type 2,
diabetes, completely gone away
that.
He thought we tried another six
months and the next meeting that
we have the next appointment he
is.
Going to, like I said, put me
back onto yellow squash, he
calls them fruits, but what he
really means is not sweet fruit.
He means yellow squash zucchini,
avocado and olives.
So I'll be able to add that,
which is okay because yellow
squash and zucchini are two of
my favorite.
What I call vegetables and
olives and avocados are my
favorite fat.
Fatty foods fatty plants to eat.
So I wonder if it'll also 0 and
with regards to how they Define
the carnivore diet, I've
discovered that I was really
leaning very heavily on Dairy
and that my regularity and my
health and my energy and all
those other things are better.
If I just stick to beef, Butter.
Bacon grease.
Processed bait, you know bacon,
I'll have it in this diet.
Chicken seems to be too lean.
Most meat seem to be too lean
once in a while.
I'll add liverwurst because I
don't eat liver, but I like
liverwurst for the nutrients
that I don't get in.
Just beef, salt, eggs are
ubiquitous Butter.
Like I said, black coffee.
Black tea water and I add this
this fancy expensive salt called
LMN T, the letters LMN T and I
do not drink the one that tastes
like sea water.
I drink the one they come in
packets.
I drink the element e additives,
that have flavor in them.
I'm suffering through some
really awful ones that I bought
Of eBay.
They're very expensive and the
ones that I bought off of eBay
are like habanero freaking lemon
habanero and like really weird.
Hot freaking strange chili lemon
chili in this crazy stuff.
Like they're so strong that I
need to dilute them more.
And when you open the packet,
the waft of waft of the powder,
literally burns, like literally
not even figuratively.
Literally.
But literally burns your nose as
if you were.
I don't know, sniffing habanero.
So how did it go?
I seem to respond very well to
being prescribed, something or
being ordered to do something,
it probably in my nature, I
really did.
Well, in JROTC being ordered and
complying isn't bad if someone,
if an external force or Me to do
it and I respect and trust them
than I do.
So mostly the kind of cheating.
I've done, like, I cheated a
week ago, and I stopped at Bob
and Edith's Diner, which is a
local like a local Famous Diner.
That's here on Columbia, Pike
and sexy, South, Arlington.
And I ordered a double bacon
cheeseburger with the bun and I
didn't order fries.
I didn't order toppings, I
didn't even order like, lettuce,
tomato and onion, or whatever.
And I considered taking the bun
off when I got home and just
making it a bacon and beef kind
of something very compliant in
the carnivore World.
In fact, I'll tell you some more
secrets that I have, but I ate
the bun, I just did.
And also as I've been going to
I'd eidos, Which is my It Cafe
on around.
That's on Walter Reed, near
Columbia Pike and I've been
eating their unmolested,
vegetable.
Omelet with rye bread toast,
whenever I order a meal there,
it's mostly eggs but there are
vegetables and the dry.
Right toast and I when I want to
cheat, I'll do that.
Otherwise, some of the things I
cheat with is I'll have I'll
have she said she's her own
chicharrones.
I'll have crispy, you know, pork
skin or whatever it's called and
that will be a cheat.
Instead of instead of chips I
will cheat with if it's not easy
to get it.
If I ran out of beef or
whatever, if I ran out of, I
will eat deli roast beef, which
you're not supposed to.
I will eat some spam, I will eat
some beef, hot dogs, I will eat
canned roast beef, which is just
awful.
I will have those kinds of
processed crappy things.
If I get caught out, Out.
And I really need a big protein
and fat beef experience.
I will order a number of
McDonald's, triple cheeseburgers
and I will throw away the buns
or give them to my crows or you
won't believe it.
I over-ordered and I went into
the park to eat my Burgers.
Leaving the bunsby.
Behind.
I might have told this story and
there was like a homeless guy
looking at me and he walked over
and I had an extra Quarter
Pounder so I gave it to him.
And then embarrassingly I said,
Hey listen, I do not want to
foist, a bunch of buns on you.
I feel like I don't want to give
like I'll never offer to a
guest.
I will never offer them
something I wouldn't enjoy
eating myself so I only have a
quarter pounder left and I will
give that to you, but I also
have like five McDonald's.
Cheeseburger, triple buns left
over as well, in these bad in
this bag and I'm intending just
to throw them out.
So if you'd like, instead of
having a 10 Patty burger with
two buns, you can have a one
patty.
Burger with 10 buns.
So he accepted I gave him a
bottle of water and that was our
interaction, but but yeah, it's
a Thing.
If you go into Reddit and you
look it up people, often times
like freaking dollar menu, the
hell at a McDonald's and throw
away.
The, you know, they might order
special or you just order the
default ones and scrape off the
stuff.
You don't want to eat.
In general, in addition to that.
And I, this is so boring.
I'm sorry.
But in addition that I generally
don't eat after 6, generally
don't eat after three, I don't
eat until like 9 or 10 in the
morning.
And so, I used to try to do one
meal a day and then not eat for
23 hours or do a 20/4.
Or 20: for diet, where I would
eat in a four hour window and
fast for 20 hours.
But the, the carnivore diet is
so relatively relatively
restricted and restrictive
anyway, that it really didn't
matter counting calories that
closely doesn't seem to matter.
There are The people in the
court of our diet might do, they
might wonder over the fridge and
take a bite out of a or cut out
of a bar of butter.
Because believe it or not.
If you're a weightlifter, you
need to keep up with your
protein but carnivore diet is
not a high protein diet.
It is a no a no carb and no
carbohydrate diet.
But it is a moderate protein and
a high fat diet and here's the
rub.
The rub is all of this stuff
requires a whole.
Heck, like the most intentional
thing in this diet and this is
really important.
The most intentional thing that
you have to keep on top of with
this diet is hydration and
making sure that you get your
electrolytes.
Like I said, those those Crazy.
Where is it donde?
Donde, donde, those crazy
element.
Let me see.
I got one here.
One, element packet.
Gives you 1000 mg of sodium, 200
milligrams of potassium in 60
milligrams of magnesium.
Now, I make sure that most of my
water has at least one packet of
Elementary in it.
I picked up an entire.
I don't know why I picked up.
101.4 fluid ounce Deer Park.
I bought two of those and so
I've got like 200 to fluid
ounces of Deer Park water and I
put two packets.
Of of Element e and each each
one they say that each packet is
enough for around 20-30 ounces
of water.
So I put in 60 ounces worth of
Element e and 100 ounces of
water.
And at that level I think that
it's, it's diluted enough.
Just to give me not to over
hydrate, you know, not too.
Over saturate me with sodium or
or do anything like that, but
make sure that the electrolytes
are kept to a good enough
standard.
So it's really important.
Here's another thing.
If you think of of If you think
of food is as medicine, you also
have to get the dose rate,
right?
So when they say 8 glasses of
water, they're referring to
someone and have 150 pounds
right to be honest.
Like hey Google, how many ounces
are in 3 l 3?
L is equivalent to 100 1.44 to
fluid ounces to Art from leaders
to fluid ounces.
Multiply units of volume by 33.8
one.
So, I theoretically need 155 to
160 5 fluid ounces of water a
day, right?
Eight glasses of water.
A day 8 times. 8 is 64 64 ounces
of water.
A day is appropriate for You
pound person.
I was a 350-pound person.
So my requirements for water
were double that, right?
So 16 glasses of water a day to
be appropriate to my physical
size.
So if you are morbidly obese and
you're only drinking 8 ounces of
water times eight a day, 64
ounces of water a day, you are
Are you are dehydrated, you're
chronically dehydrated and it's
not easy.
They say it's not easy to
maintain to maintain three and
fifty pounds but it's it's
enjoyable, right?
Like being like being fat is its
own reward, right?
You get to eat and eat and eat.
If you love eating then
freaking, you get to eat and eat
and eat, right?
Like it's not, it's not torture
if you heat food.
Maintaining 350 pounds is hard,
but drinking 165 155. 150 ounces
of water.
Every day.
You can just like, if you don't
pay attention, ours will go away
and you won't have any water and
you need to make sure that you
are not getting dehydrated.
One thing that my withing scale
does is it tells me when I'm
losing A muscle when I'm losing
bone density and when I'm
losing, when I'm under hydrated.
So even though I don't weigh
myself that often I am
currently, and I need to work
out way more.
I walk a lot, but I need to get
onto my urge and I need to get
to the gym and do some serious
weight training because like my
muscles are atrophying when I
get back, I'll tell you how
much, how much torture really
was being 350 pounds.
I'll talk to you in a few.
I don't know.
Is it on apple plus TV Apple TV
Plus or where is it?
But there's a TV show called the
consultant and this is going to
be a I'll give you warning like
if you haven't seen the show yet
I don't want there to be
spoilers but one of the issues
in the show is that the
consultant can't climb stairs
without help.
And it turns out that this
magical creature is Only Human
by appearance and that he is
sort of if you will a, an evil
Pagan Golem and he was created
by the hands of a jeweler who
hand created every single bone
in a human skeleton.
Out of gold.
So according to Google an entire
human skeleton.
Made of gold is 200 pounds.
Hey Google, how much is a human
skeleton made completely out of
gold. 0.2 mg on the website
India.
Today.in.
OK.
Google.
How much would a human skeleton
way if it were made out of gold
On the website William L Han.com
they say.
If all that massive bone,
converted to Gold, the total
weight would be 102.9 six
kilograms of gold and treasure
on the hoof.
People also, sometimes ask me
how much do skeletons way?
Do you want to hear the answer?
No.
So the irony here is that I am
aspiring.
The funny thing here is that I'm
aspiring to be 100 kg and a
human skull made entirely out of
gold.
Would be 102 kg which is around
120. 220 something pounds and
that is what it's like being 350
pounds, right?
It's like having a 150 pound
body and then submit the, the
bones on their own or around 20
pounds.
So a, a gold bones would be if
you will 200 more pounds than
regular bones skeleton, skeletal
bones, so that extra 200 pounds.
Is exactly what I had on my body
when I was 350 pounds.
So if you picture it and you
see, You see the consultant
unable to walk up and down
stairs.
You'll reach.
And because he's having these
troubles because he is 120 130,
140 pound man, trying to carry
an extra two hundred and twenty
pounds upstairs and downstairs.
You'll realize the challenges
that people who are morbidly
obese have and I'm not I've only
lost 50 pounds have another.
I've another 100 pounds to lose
and so I'm not adjusted yet.
I do not, I do find it.
Much easier to come go up and
down stairs, but I am still
uncomfortable with my footing, I
still feel insecure, I still
feel self-conscious, I still
feel like everybody's looking at
me and I still tend to stick to
the elevators.
I was down at the convenience
store today.
Buying these big bottles of Deer
Park water and the women down
there is the owners aunty. and
even though we're probably
around the same age, she tends
to Mother me a little bit and
today she told me that she
really noticed the weight loss
and asked me if I had lost
weight and then warned me that
maybe I'm losing weight too
quickly and I don't know,
someone whom I might have had an
eating disorder.
When I was in high school
wrestling.
I might have liked to not eat
ever and felt Superior to
everybody around me by not
eating and going out with my
friends, to McDonald's and
feeling Superior to them,
because I only would drink
glasses of water at McDonald's.
Those kind of things, but and
then needing to get below 180.
As a six foot three kid in
muscular wrestler, to have to do
all of my runs and in rubber
suits, and it all the time, and
chew, bubblegum, and chew gum,
and spit the water out and other
kinds of crazy things.
I might have eating disorder
predilection, that sort of But I
do not think that I lost weight
too fast.
In fact, it was extremely slow
and I hit setbacks and I hit
plateaus and I would get injured
and feel sorry for myself and
maybe have a pint of ice cream
or do something like that.
And so, I did hit a number of
plateaus so I feel like the
here's the thing.
Here's the thing about the The
exponential, the ability to when
you lose weight, it's
exponentially easier to lose
more weight.
And let me explain.
It's like the hockey stick,
right?
You barely can hobble around it
for me.
Six foot three 53. 52 or
whatever.
Moving around 32 50 pounds isn't
easy, right?
I would go on these walks and so
forth but like I would walk
slow, you know, it would burn a
lot of calories if you were
three and 50 pounds.
It's like rucking with 150
pounds in your back, right?
You do people get pissed when
they see when I go to spin class
and stuff.
How many calories I burned but
they adjust for how much you
Way, right?
So it's all proportionate
calories, don't be jealous.
But the lighter, I get, the more
I want to be active.
The more I want to be outside.
The more I want to get on the
Urge of the rowing machine,
which of the same thing, or the
skier or the or even my bicycle
outside and taking the stairs.
And all these other things are
becoming more and more opened up
to me with the goal.
That I want to do a weekly
parkrun every Saturday at
Roosevelt Island.
I want to get on my bike cycle,
down there, do a slow jogging 5K
and then you know, meet new
people and maybe you know,
afterwards walk in a DC or bike
in a DC, you know, living
outdoorsy kind of Life.
Have some fun in the city that
I'm in be a little bit less.
Of a shut-in if I am and there's
a lot to look forward to.
I am not going to change this
diet, but if the doctor says
that I should have zucchini and
yellow squash and avocado, and
olives, I will really enjoy
adding those things.
I would love love to along, you
know, to have a plate bisected
with, you know, Beef on one side
and a big thing of sautéed
butter.
I can do that butter, sauteed,
zucchini and yellow squash on
the other what a joy and and I
feel like it's really getting
closer.
I feel like it's getting really
Other news, right?
After this break,
So, in addition to, this, my
friend kaushik has an open
invitation to me, to go to the
gym during the hours that he's
there.
So I will be heading down,
starting next week, probably
every day down to Crystal City
and to the gym down there and
spend, you know, two hours and
evening just getting my gym, rat
feedback, you know, doing some
some not Some Smith.
Some body weight, exercises
dumbbells.
I don't know if they have any
free weights, but I would like
to at least emulate deadlifts
and emulate other types of
things and squats and machines
and pull-downs, and lat
pull-downs and heavy rows and
leg presses and all that other
fun stuff, I'm really excited
about it.
And I'll just go down there
every day.
Like, I'll bring my phone so I
could do, if I want, I can do a
or data, I can do my rowing down
there, I can do whatever it
takes down there.
I can take my meds at like 6
p.m. and then immediately, turn
around and bicycle and
eventually jog down to Planet
Fitness and Crystal City Hit or
Miss.
Whether or not, I see kaushik
He's really having some great
success.
Really getting pumped every day.
Getting completely jacked.
He's like the, he's like the
He's completely become a Marvel
hero.
He says that he only has a swell
that he only has like that.
He's only jacked for an hour
after he works out, but that's
the way everybody's everybody's
body works out especially if
they're not extremely lean.
So everybody has a pump at the
gym.
Has a pump right after the Jim.
That's why when people are about
to do their, their big photo
shoots or their shirtless scenes
in movies and televisions, they
always do so ABS, I've got to
do.
Lots and lots of ABS, I've got
to do burpees, I've got to do
planks.
I've got to do roller ABS.
I've got to do all these things.
And so I'm really excited to
start doing that.
I'll start next week. and, You
know, we'll see what happens,
like, the last six months have
felt like forever, right.
It's been so many times of
desperation and, you know,
honestly, I don't feel that much
thinner.
I'm the clothes don't hang off
me.
I don't really notice whether
I've the fifty pounds is just,
you know, did I keep all the
wrong places?
Like, I don't feel Like I'm
swimming in my clothes, I don't
feel like my jeans are
completely loose and baggy on
me, I don't feel like I'm ready
to be at the point of buying an
entirely new wardrobe.
So that might be such a an
extreme amount of obesity of
morbid obesity on me that it's
like, inconceivable, but I take
it that the next 80 to 100
pounds is going to be much more
noticeable.
Isabel and I'm very excited
about it.
So that's the strategy.
The strategy is, and it worked
right?
Whatever they say about Kita or
whatever they say about
intermittent fasting or whatever
they say about carnivore diet.
You know, recently in the last
few days there's been a lot of
articles about how the keto diet
is going to give you strokes and
make you die.
But having an extra Frick an
extra 200 pounds, 100, get 200.
Extra basically if we're going
to compare everything to 150
pounds, like I should be 180,
right?
So it's it's 170. 170, extra
pounds, right?
That's that's a lot of that's
Anand.
That's like carrying around a
pretty good.
Shaped five-foot-ten, like, man,
like, on my back all the time
or, you know, like a normal
shape to American woman.
Hey goal, what's the average
weight of an American woman?
Hey, Google, what is the average
170 points 6 pounds on the
website Health line.com.
They say the average American
woman, 20 years old, and up
weighs 170 point six pounds and
stands at sixty three point
seven inches tall, and the
average waist.
Circumference, it's thirty eight
point six inches.
So it's like walking around with
an average American woman on top
of me, all the, or like, on my
back, like, on my front on my
sides all the time.
And that's what it's like.
So I still don't feel it.
Like I still, it's all numbers.
It's all numbers and what other
people see, and, and weigh-ins
and so forth.
I'm just not feeling.
I look in the mirror, I see the
same fat face.
I look in the mirror.
I see the same gigantic belly,
like I do not see it yet and I'm
hoping to really start Either
I've got, you know, body
dysmorphia where I cannot see
the loss of weight in the
mirror.
Like it's literally impossible
for now or it just hasn't turned
a corner and there's just been
so much fluff and so much extra
weight that I that it's not
really going to like the final
hundred is going to be the real
change maker there.
So I'm hoping for that.
Until then I'm going to be is
extremely strict as I can be.
When I gave up carbs and in
March 2020, I gave up drinking,
you know how like your friends
are like the moment I gave up
beer, the moment I gave up bread
or whatever.
I melted weights like that
didn't happen to me like I have
to be really vigorous and
rigorous like I have to aim at
1500 calories every day.
Even though I know it'll either
be 2000 or 2500 by the end of
the day, just because of, you
know, dumb shit need to be
careful not to eat too late.
I need to be careful about what
I do.
Eat, I get to be careful about
portion control.
I have to be careful about all
those things because I do not
have the satiation button
anymore.
What I I made a joke today that
someone didn't laugh at about
gluttony.
In my, you know, mortal sin
sometimes sloth but oftentimes
gluttony and I think that if you
have a combination of sloth and
gluttony, those are very hard
things to know to live through,
right?
Those the reasons why gloss
sloth and gluttony are on the
seven.
Deadly sins is because they're
literally deadly sins, right?
Murder might be deadly to
someone.
Else.
But gluttony and sloth is murder
to yourself like gluttony and
sloth are a kind of, I wouldn't
say it's an Irish suicide
because that's drinking yourself
to death or that's getting drunk
and having a cop kill you.
But I would say, maybe it's an
American suicide.
American suicide is through
sloth and gluttony I do not know
if that's true anymore because
the Fentanyl and opioid crisis,
but I would say, traditionally
speaking, heart disease and the
other kinds of chronic.
Chronic diseases that result in
early death Nat, they call them
natural death.
But like those kumu
comorbidities that allow you to
get struck down by simple things
like colds, and flus and so
forth are things.
You really have to worry about
anyway.
I really appreciate you
listening to me.
I don't know if this was useful
at all, I didn't script it.
So it's completely completely
off the cuff and it shows I can
tell already that it is a
complete giant mass but
hopefully one person on Mastodon
will appreciate it and I will
talk to you soon with closing
remarks.
Love you guys.
All right, season 5, episode 2
about my journey.
I do not know if I covered
everything or nothing, if you
have questions, please let me
know.
You can follow me on Mastodon at
Chris at Abraham .su you can
email me chris@chrisderose.com,
you can call or text me at + 12
0 to 35 to 50 51.
You can find me at Chris
Abraham.com.
You can find me at Twitter at
Chris Abraham on Twitter at
Chris Abraham on Instagram.
You can find me Chris Dash,
Abraham.com on Tumblr.
I am user, Chris Abraham on
Reddit.
And if you use plus 1 20 to 35,
to 50 51, I think you can also
like, I said, text me, but you
can also telegram me, you can
signal me, you can WhatsApp me,
etcetera, etc, etc.
So that's it.
You can follow me or subscribe
to me on any of the Casting
platforms, but my home base has
anchored FM /.
Chris Abraham?
Maybe?
I don't know.
And I'll talk to you soon,
please.
Give me any kind of feedback.
I'd be really appreciative.
Lots of love.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.
Hey.